[Music]
but yesterday was a day to forget if
you're a Detroit Lions fan it was day
10,000 since the franchise's last
postseason victory that came January 5
1992 against the Dallas Cowboys the
following week the Lions would lose to
Washington in the NFC Championship game
and not win a playoff game since then
marathon of misery 10k and there's that
sign Oh in 16 we did it first take that
Cleveland Brown so that inspires today's
draft and you know I say this all time
there are fan bases out there that
desperately deserve to have winning
teams relevant teams teams that make it
to the playoffs once in a while beyond
just accidentally and also winning in
the postseason not many teams even
though it's an age of parity Chris get
to enjoy being victorious in the
postseason so we're gonna draft the fan
bases that we think are most deserving
of a playoff victory go ahead I'm
deserving of a coin toss victory maybe
I'll get one don't really I'm on a toss
I'm like the New England Patriots of
coin tosses okay I'm gonna go with tails
here I think she thinks I'm gonna go
with heads thinking you want to win and
she's gonna go with tails yes I am on
fire like I seriously would like to know
my statistics with heads and tails over
the last like 60 days I think I'm like
55 and five I think she's cheating I
think she waits until you make the call
and then she hits heads or tails
she doesn't think there's anything ray
doesn't like me that much she doesn't
like me that much to know she died but
she dislikes me enough to do it that had
very valid point maybe that could be
true all right this is fairly obvious
okay
now this is not a team that's had
necessarily okay the longest playoff
drought but damn I'm going with the team
that's had the longest playoff win
drought and that's the Cincinnati
Bengals I'm so sick of hearing about the
Cincinnati Bengals and having won a
playoff game and whatever and oh my gosh
Marvin Lewis it's all we talked about
every year so you know I look at that
and the Bengals fan base still been very
loyal over the years gets crapped on a
lot of different ways but I do I feel
sorry for them I know they got to the
playoffs but there hasn't been a lot too
bond there with the Cincinnati Bengals
and they have not won a playoff game
since the 1990 wild-card round so yeah I
went with the team with the longest
drought because I do feel bad for them
and I feel like that's always the
narrative around the Cincinnati Bengals
yeah but but again it's it's it's not
what organization it's what fanbase and
and I'm sorry but they don't fill the
stadium consistently enough for me in
Cincinnati and anybody who pays to go
see a bad team play and shows up and
sits in the upper deck upper rows of the
upper deck out in the elements out in
the cold and is there no matter what
those are the fan bases that deserve it
and I got to stay in Ohio Chris to
Cleveland Browns this edition of the
Browns has never won a playoff game and
I don't know how much solace you take if
you're a Browns fan how do you
compartmentalize this idea that well the
Browns left and became the Ravens and
they've won two Super Bowls and the the
new Browns of the old brown so we still
get to enjoy whatever success the old
Browns had but we know it's still a
different franchise all together I mean
this franchise has been around for 20
years now and has not won a playoff game
they've been to one playoff game and
those fans show up all the time there's
never talked about games not being sold
out in Cleveland they are there all the
time and they are behind that team
unconditionally unequivocally so I think
I right state wrong city Cleveland
Browns I think the obvious winner yeah
well I guess the reason I you know III
guess you know my biggest reason for
that first of all there's been plenty of
games where I've looked at Cleveland
Browns Stadium and gun there's there's
not a great fan showing there and that
it wasn't last year but the two years
before that and I get that so I'm just
pushing back here for the sake of the
draft okay it's every week in Cincinnati
every week in Cincinnati I just feel
like the Bengals fans get crapped on
more that's where I look at it too to
where I just kind of get sick of that
that's why I went with number one but I
don't think I don't think they'd I just
think that there's the Bengals are just
kind of there the fan base is just kind
of there that's my vibe on under and it
proved us wrong Bengals win some games
one of the vision fill up your Stadium
every week but I just feel like they're
just kind of there okay all right I got
you all right my next one here I'm gonna
go with the team we just broke down as
far as offseason addition I'm going with
the Buffalo Bills you talk about these
Panda
oh they gave him access Wednesday so
he's going with the bills what that's
right you know I got to stay friends
with my friends there make sure they
still love me okay but in all
seriousness I mean come on that's an
unbelievable fan base up there in
Orchard New York they deal with the
elements the wind the cold you know the
tailgating experience they're out there
they're as loyal as hell up there in
Buffalo an unbelievable fan base the
Buffalo Bills are part of this the the
DNA of the city
it truly is special they haven't won a
playoff game since 1995 but they
continue to show up no matter what it is
they know that the Patriots are gonna
win the AFC East they're still there in
support so I look at them as a fan base
towards the top of the list and maybe
this should have been my first pick for
some of the things they've had to endure
just say that they deserve better and
and I think the better is coming very
soon yeah I think the Bills fans do
deserve it I think browns should have
been first bills should have been my
first pick but the Bills definitely
deserve it they've been through so much
and they stuck with that team it's just
how excruciating every year to go back
to the Super Bowl and not win it and
still be with that team would have been
very easy to say after that fourth
Superbowl all right we had our chance
fun's over let's let's just go pay
attention to hockey now instead so
they're still behind that team zealously
behind that team and they got to worry a
little bit about what the Pegula's are
gonna do with that team long-term
hopefully hopefully they can find a way
to keep that team in western New York
because that team should stay there
indefinitely all right this next one is
going to surprise I think fan bases
sometimes get confused if I'm critical
of a team I'm not being critical with a
fan base if I'm critical of a
quarterback I'm not being critical of
the fan base sometimes we call teams out
in the hopes that they get better so
they can give the fan base what they
deserve and frankly Chris the Oakland
Raiders fan base deserves a playoff win
in this year the year that the Raiders
are leaving Oakland for the second time
and I don't think they're coming back
at some point down the road this time
around they haven't won a postseason
games since the super bowl run in 2002
and
what an ugly taste in the mouth still
lingering now after what happened when
Jon Gruden went to Tampa and the
Buccaneers and the Raiders got together
and the Buccaneers just flattened the
Raiders they've been to the playoffs one
time since then they've been horrible
more often than they've been relevant
they were they were blown off the field
in their one playoff game a couple of
years ago because Derek Carr had a
broken leg but the Raiders fans what
they've gone through how their
heartstrings have been pulled over the
years and how they've been jerked around
they deserve to see that team leave
Oakland with a playoff win and here's
hoping that they play well enough that
they actually have a home game it's
gonna be hard to do with the Chiefs and
the charges in the division but you know
Raiders fans are mad at me because I
Derek Carr is not the answer long-term
look they know deep deep down he's not
the answer long-term there's nothing
else they can do about it but the
Raiders deserve Raiders fans deserve
that postseason win and hopefully they
get it this year before they leave
Oakland yeah one of the most awesome fan
bases in all of football I mean come on
all the characters in the black hole and
doctors dressed up as you know in all
different costumes and it's just a
one-of-a-kind place to attend a football
game Matt it really is whether it's
driving up in the bus through the
tailgating area or being out there on
the football field it's got a unique
energy they love their Raiders and I'm
with you it's sad to see that the
Raiders are not gonna be a part of that
Oakland City anymore and that is a fan
base that's extremely loyal all right my
third pick here I'm not sure what I want
to do I'm conflicted a little bit I
really am here because you know there's
one team on here that's very close to my
heart and the Tampa Bay Buccaneers and I
know that fan base I love that fan base
but I think just for the sake of the
draft here I'm going to pick the Detroit
Lions fans okay I got to go up to
Detroit I mean they haven't won a damn
payoff game since 1991 they still show
up for Thanksgiving games you know NSC
north football still fun to watch on a
weekly basis no matter who comes into
town in Detroit whether it's the Packers
the Vikings the Bears whoever they're
always seems to be you know good
electricity in that Stadium the fans
seem to be there in support yeah maybe
you've complained about you know the
fact that
you know Matthew Stafford at times I get
sick of defending that but there's
passion there in Detroit they want a
winner it's a great sports city I love
Detroit people in general their
blue-collar they love football we know
the state of Michigan loves football I
look at them and go they deserve it
I really look at Matt Stafford he
deserves it but they have dim the fans
deserve it more than anything up there
and and I'm hoping that the current
management of the team has patience with
Bob Quinn and Matt Patricia and lets
them implement the culture change they
are pushing back against 60 years of
organizational dysfunction that does
manifest itself in the chronic struggles
10,001 day now since not that they could
have done anything about in the last 24
hours but the streak is now 10,001 days
without a playoff win and I had the
Lions you know we last week big cat and
I had this conversation and the clip
went a little viral had about 500,000
views of the camera focusing on big cat
while he's kind of making a face as I
say the Lions are a team that people are
sleeping on I still believe it and I
feel like when it when it finally
happens for Detroit's gonna happen
quickly it's gonna happen suddenly and
people are gonna be stunned
yeah I'm with you to Detroit's one of
those teams where yeah I'm not picking
him to win the NFC North but they would
classify as one of those teams where I
would go okay I wouldn't be shocked if
they were in the playoff conversation in
December but sitting here in May I'm not
going to pick them to win the NFC North
or really be in second or third place
really a little bit a lot like the
Titans we talked about I'm picking them
to be last in the NFC North but it's a
good football team that I'm picking to
be last now III you were conflicted
between the lines and the bucking errors
and and look the Buccaneers of the
obvious team left on the board I only
hesitate because I remember watching a
game last year in the NBC viewing room
and they had a wide shot of the stadium
and there's just nobody there now I
don't know how much I fault the fan base
for that because how much of that can
you take before you just say I'm out
right because this is a very passionate
fan base we get the updates all the time
from Tony Dungy goes to Foster's
barbershop and they get electrified when
the Buccaneers are good the problem is
they aren't good
often enough so you just you you're in
Florida right you got plenty of other
things you can do than worry about the
football team if they are just going to
stink and the fact that there's a Super
Bowl trophy lingering I think it makes
it easier to check out you have to give
that fanbase a reason to check in
they're trying to do it this year and
yeah I mean none of these other team
while the Raiders have their Super Bowl
trophies but you know these other teams
the bills the Lions the Bengals the
Browns they don't even have one the
Buccaneers at least have one but I just
feel like they deserve something better
than what they've gotten it's been too
much impatience from ownership when it
comes to firing coaches there hasn't
been that year-to-year consistency they
need to develop something and that they
really are making an all-in move I don't
know that it's gonna work but that
fanbase deserves better than what it's
got yeah you know it I mean I love that
fanbase as it's a way more loyal you
know crazy fan based and I think you
know the national media maybe gives it
credit for and I think a little bit is
because of what you say you know yeah
it's Florida someday when the team is 2
and 7 yeah people aren't tuned you know
coming out and in in droves to go to
Tampa Bay Buccaneers football games -
the other thing I think you gotta take
in - you know I think a little
consideration about the economics of the
city with some of these things - you
know yeah you know the the Giants can
sell out a stadium here in New York when
they're 2 and 8 because they got season
ticket holders that can not show up and
just throw money at the door for all I
got for season tickets I don't need to
show up I'm making good money you know
sometimes in Tampa there's just not
enough rich people to go around and some
of those cities like that - to where I
want to go people can you know just be
attached to season tickets year after
year after year especially when the team
hasn't been good so I do think that
affects the way it looks on TV I guess
is what I'm trying to say well then you
should have picked him both ways you
should have picked him I should about
them yeah but you want you under to have
it both ways
yeah but he's doesn't work that way
you've lost this week is you lost at the
moment you picked the Bengals lines I
did I got the Browns Raiders in Bucks at
least I can I lose
well no you can't because you lose far
more often than today we're gonna take a
break when we return chris has a
homework assignment for next week so
much for your three-day weekend buddy
you're gonna be working because you got
a lot of work to do I already got ready
I'm a teacher stuff I got it done before
the homeworks ready don't you worry
never mind we'll tell you what it is
when PFT life continues
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports